des autographes des photos des échanges
entre les joueurs et les supporters ils
étaient plus d'une centaine à venir
rencontrer les hommes de didier
deschamps à clairefontaine
l'accueil toujours extraordinaire et
puis on est on est là pour la france un
dernier entraînement ouvert au public
avant le départ pour la coupe du monde
en russie les bleues ont pu constater la
ferveur autour de l'équipe de france
face voilà on est soutenir non on est
soutenu et nous avons voix voilà
toujours à plus de rencontrer les
supporters on passe un bon moment avec
nous permet de voir tout le monde qui
est derrière nous
[Musique]
pour mettre l'ambiance les bleus peuvent
compter sur les irrésistibles français
ce groupe de supporters créé en 2002
compte plus de 1000 adhérents parmi eux
ce couple de maurepas sylvain et
jennifer charvaux a pas la possibilité
d'aller en russie
donc on va leur montrer que nous mêmes
restant en france on est là et on sera
toujours derrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jennifer et sylvain ont rejoint les
irrésistibles français pour l'ambiance
participation au match rencontre avec
les joueurs dédicaces des maillots de
nombreux souvenirs conservés on a
quelques autres graves dont sudo dimegio
ici et de griezmann
ici le 12 juillet 98 c'était le plus
beau jour du foot français
vingt ans après ce titre ils attendent
une performance des hommes de didier
deschamps durant ce mondial avec
beaucoup d'émotion stressant énormément
stressant comme ça qu'on voit là comme
chaque coupe du monde chaque coupe
d'europe on aimerait la voir au plus
haut au plus haut comme en 98 euros
vivre ces expériences là c'est
magnifique et c'est pour ça nous on se
bat pour ça le foot nous donne tellement
de joie que c'est ça vient de là c'est
une passion autour de ce sport vécu en
couple jennifer et sylvain reste en
france mais leur coeur bat pour les
bleus en russie on va la gagner chez toi